you know that one piece is long right
yeah everyone does but no one really
actually understands just how [__]
long this thing is one piece has been
going on for so long now that it has
appeared before South Park episode one
the creation of Netflix Google being
registered as a [__] domain name and
what's more is when one piece started
Michael Jordan was in the middle of his
second repeat with the Chicago Bulls
Hugo slavia it was still a [__]
country the United States conflict in
Afghanistan wasn't to start for another
two [__] years and Dragon Ball GT was
still brand new one piece is so old that
its beginning is closer to the fall of
the Soviet Union than we are to current
modern day
buy a white margin